so let's try and remember I wonder if
you can come back with me I've given you
some clues here right let's think back
to binomial theorem what was the very
first thing that we learn within a
really simple thing actually something
you've note all the way since he's seven
any takers
it looks it looks like this yeah I can't
hurt it Pascal's triangle right so we
started by just having a look at the
numbers that appear in Pascal's triangle
right 1 1 at 1 1 2 1 1 3 3 1 etc and
where is hey that's kind of cool
that this this pattern that we see
coming up here ends up being really
useful when you are trying to expand
binomials what do we mean by poner
binomials the by binomial of course just
means to like a bicycle right so
binomial means when you've got two terms
and if you expand such a thing if you
just do it like if you're brute force
like just expand and do it
you know after million lines of working
you see these coefficients emerge you
can like that's that's kind of cool
right so we did a bunch of questions
just using that but if we said ok the
whole point of this is to say let's
let's not just observe some cool
patterns let's try and dig into these
things right so we introduced the idea
that let's try and think about the
numbers you get out of this in a logical
and formal way and we called them
because they're the coefficients they
come from a biodome you expansion we
call these objects like these things we
name them
binomial coefficients their coefficients
that come from when you take a binomial
and you expand it right now insert do we
we noticed that these binomial
coefficients were remarkably well sorry
this binomial expansion every term that
you got out of it for example this one
here can we do this one X plus y to the
power of 5 do you remember what the
fifth row is like I'll give you a clue
it starts with a 1 and a 5 how many
times you're gonna have think about it
if it's the fifth row down it's a fifth
row down here's the 0 or throw first row
second row third row fourth row fifth
how many terms it'll be six it's always
one more right so you're going to have
if it's six terms then it's one of these
symmetrical ones where you've got the
same number on it's an even number of
both sides right so the next one will be
ten there you get ten again because you
got three now so you got to get the
other three which are at the same in
Reverse right so you're going to get
let's quickly do this expansion and
redraw your memory your money
now check up you're going to get the
first term we'll have lots of extras on
it that's the one right that's okay
your favor someone help me out next time
I've done I've done most of the work for
you that's the hard part to remember
what comes next
okay very good so you start with lots of
X's right and then the X is sort of
climbed down in power and you're wise
sort of climb up in power remember that
so you're gonna have X to the 4 y yes it
started to ring bells what am I gonna
have next 10x very good it goes up down
one more and up one wall will keep going
you're gonna have one less of these one
more of these second last you still have
one of these left and then lastly no
more X's all the wires take over
remember this yeah is it ringing bells
now as you can see so you sort of get
into a rhythm right each term in the
binomial is composed of three parts it's
three parts every single time you get
the binder your coefficient just that
number right then you have some number
of X's and some number of Y's sometimes
you have zero lots of Y of 0 lots of
experts still sort of there right so
being that every single term is sort of
excuse me in the same format right we
said oh man we don't need to write all
six of these they all sort of fit into
this template right so we said well why
don't we just say you've got the sum of
a whole bunch of things that all look
very much the same right that all have
the same binomial coefficient at the
front some number X is some number of
Y's now do you remember what notation we
introduced to say when you've got the
psalm
of a bunch of things that all look the
saved remember that yeah we said Sigma
notation and the Sigma is just the Greek
letter for s because we're just saying
sub right add those things up so we
introduce Sigma notation for that we
said yeah it's the sum of a bunch of
things from we count from zero we go up
to five zero one two three four five
will give us the six terms that we have
here and then we say in this case it'll
be good morning 5c ah x ^ ah I did this
backwards but anyway and then one of her
in five - are really fine right so we
say hey you know what every single term
all six of them we wrote in this
expansion they all kind of look like
this you see that you've got your
binomial coefficient some number X's
snub number of wires okay this is just
saying Adam walled up right so we
introduced Sigma notation as a very nice
neat way of doing this and that became
handy later on when we came back to
series and sequences and we said hey
this is this is the same idea or series
is exactly this right
and then you turn one last year you're
doing really well few remember you so
far we covered one last thing we said
okay all of this stuff right
particularly this guy we can notice that
these numbers appear in Pascal's
triangle right and that's kind of neat
it's kind of cool but when they really
come from like what's the what's the
formula that is making each of these
things work and importantly like I
wanted to develop a formula because if I
want to know like the eleventh row right
if I have X plus y to the power of 11
okay I don't really want to have to
create this table and draw everything
all the way down to the eleventh row
that's a very time-consuming process so
we had to introduce some new notation
right do you remember what thing in
binary other had to do with don't let F
River oh very good factorials right well
should I say factorials because we used
an exclamation point to indicate them
why is it an excellent
can point by the way do you remember why
did we use that symbol in our language
an exclamation point indicates something
crazy or surprising right one factorial
is 1 2 factorial is help me out 2 3
factorial is 6 4 factorial 4 factorial 6
times 4 says 24 then you go 120 then you
go 720
there you go 5040 this guy this guy as a
function it just skyrockets okay it's
faster than everything it's even faster
than the exponential function which is
saying something because that's like our
definition of exponential growth is a
really fast thing right factorials even
faster now the reason why we introduced
factorials is because you said this
thing here right this mysterious pattern
you can build it from addition right but
if you want to go directly there that in
fact we can create a formula for this
that says I can work out a T binomial
coefficient this this notation which
maybe you prefer this one whichever is
fine you do need to recognize but we can
state it as something a fraction in
terms of factorials once you know what
factorials are right does anyone
remember what has what's on this
fraction there's three factorials that
appear yeah okay work pause all right
we've got very good n factorial at the
top and then there are two factorials
remaining down the bottoms they don't
remember what they are
let's see anyone else okay are you
different very good okay so if you
crunch this out you'll realize that the
numbers in Pascal's triangle they just
sort of they're they aren't they emerge
right and it's it's quite an amazing
thing now we are going to come back to
this idea of like where it comes from
because we're mostly at the beginning of
year 11 we didn't really have the bits
and pieces to kind of explain like what
what the Dickens is going on here why
should those three factorials combine in
a fraction of all things a fraction do
you notice how weird it is that there's
a fraction in here because visitings
here we just get them by addition then
all whole numbers every single one but
if you form your numbers this way all
your fractions just kind of come out in
the water right